I was abused any one human being can be
abused as a kid so I don't know I've
been bullied all the time it had a
profound effect on me being bullied them
I wish you didn't but it had real
profound effect um um I'm Akane I'm a
really sensitive guy and I'm um how can
I explain this um from being Billy I
could be really I'm really bummed
malevolent you know I didn't like to
talk like that but yeah I'm being a
bully um I got um being bullied you can
you come you can track them a really
disgusting um terminal cancer in you is
something you never forget
uess never forget it it's anyway um
brutally being attacked us in any way
anybody could be bullied is bullied Rob
taking advantaged of my use um I just
wanted that to stop but and when I met
cuff you know it stopped a little but
there's always bigger kid you know you
have fighting a bigger kind of men
descend a little but once I met cut from
D'Amato was a totally I believe bully
was all psychological now you know
learning he's not allowed to do that
because my fear locked by fear I'm
consumed being allowed him to take
advantage of me I didn't know that one
with the kid so I looked at bullying
totally different now so somebody was to
bully me I'm now that I don't think is
nothing wrong with stabbing him a
shooting him so I came up in that kind
of world you know the guys bigger
stronger than you you you you drop you
drop out television on focusing on the
tough from the roof yes this is what you
do for my neighborhood you don't allow
people to bully you just don't want to
do that you don't have that reputation
they just sucker